[Musik]
hallo herzlich willkommen so salis welt
letztes mal kam der top box challenge
richtig gut bei euch an heute werde ich
wieder ein drei-gänge-menü zaubern
aber ich weiß noch nicht mit welchen
produkten daniela unser freund und er
hat mit heidi brandnew spox mitgebracht
denn daniele denn kennen ja vielleicht
schon einige von euch denn wir haben ja
schon mal ein video oder mehrere schon
zusammen gemacht und zwar hast du ja die
paybox sozusagen erfunden bestellt und
da sind immer neue produkte drin oder
produkte die man noch nicht so kennt
richtig dass neue produkte drin und eben
natürlich produkte von herstellern von
kleineren herzustellen vom staat und den
wir natürlich auch die möglichkeit haben
geben dass ich mal bekannt gemacht
werden
ich bin sehr gespannt was du heute
zuhause ich auch vor allem haben so die
kleineren start ups auch die möglichkeit
den weg in den supermarkt und zu euch zu
finden was ich ziemlich cool finde und
daniele unterstützt uns auch immer denn
für unseren online shop schickst du uns
auch immer die kleinen pakete er
sponsert uns da damit ihr auch mit
kleine überraschung immer bei eurer
bestellung mit dabei habt und wer mich
natürlich auch dich unterstützen und
haben gesagt die cobox challenge die
machen wir jetzt noch mal und ich bin
echt gespannt darauf denn ich weiß noch
nicht was drinnen steckt und ich werde
jetzt ein drei-gänge-menü zaubern fertig
und im rat für dich toll ich bin sehr
gespannt und verletzte mann so sehr
lecker und dem springen wo ich mich
heute wieder was probieren zu dürfen
also hier sind die produkte drin
ich packte aus aber ich darf frische
produkte ergänzen ja absolut klar das
ist auf jeden fall möglich wir haben
aber auch ein paar sachen dazu gepackt
die vielleicht gar nicht mehr neu sind
aber die man dann super der auch
kombinieren cartier sehen wir ja nachher
nochmal und wenn du fragen hast du dir
als du kannst du mich immer gerne
ok dann machen wir das wir packen das
jetzt zusammen aus und du bist immer
ansprechbar
ich bin gespannt was ich dazu sagen
möchte es eine gekühlte box und bei
brandnooz gibt es übrigens verschiedene
boxen also die hier ist einmalig aber
ihr habt doch die möglichkeit monatlich
was auszuprobieren gekühlte boxen es
gibt verschiedene themenbereiche wie zum
beispiel barbecue boxen und ich glaube
das hilft euch einfach dabei euer
lieblings produkt zu finden also bei uns
ist auch so wir gehen gerne einkaufen
und kaufen immer ein produkt was wir
noch nicht kennen was man normalerweise
einfach nicht macht weil was man nicht
kennt ist man mal meistens auch nicht
nur probiert nicht und da habt ihr
einfach die möglichkeit
so gott sei dank etwas bekanntes
gasgrill und fallen käse was ich aber
noch nicht kannte und ich wusste hier
gibt es einen 4 in 1 grill max ziemlich
cool
nach 41 honey bee gees neu chili kenne
ich kräuter kenn ich natur kenne ich und
zwar ist es ein grill käse den er in der
pfanne zubereitet richtig lecker ganz
schön kross anbraten ihr könnt in den
würfel schneiden und anbraten als spieße
machen
und ja diesmal probleme das ist aus und
ich bin schon gespannt darauf wie hanni
barbecue schmeckt also gott sei dank ein
produkt was ich kenne daniel ja das ist
der rote die akkupacks endlich mal raus
ok eine bunte mischung veganes mühlen
viel von der rügenwalder mühle reicher
ungesättigten fettsäuren weg vegan ist
es was ist das ein mühlen vieles ist und
praktisch wie kann man das sagen wieso
ein schnitzel aber begann
ok ich finde ich ziemlich cool denn
letztes mal hatte ich hackfleisch auch
von der rügenwalder mühle und das mag
vielleicht aber auch vegan und der murat
kam nicht darauf dass es ein veganes
hackfleisch war das war ziemlich witzig
das war vegane schnell handeln ich
schätze versteckt werden wir nutzen sie
nicht gesagt hat ist hätte ich nie was
kommt dass vegetarier veganer dann habe
ich hier einen gespräch man das aus
frage von total 02 ist das ein joghurt
ab tokyo wird nach griechischem
rezeptfrei 02 griechischer joghurt ist
stichfest ich bin mal gespannt und
bestimmt auch mit regen und proteine
reicht genau womit 0,2 prozent fett
da bin ich gespannt was aus sorge
momentan habe ich noch keine idee aber
ich werde schon irgendwas machen
[Applaus]
[Musik]
vielleicht also darf er ist direkt
spontan das erste ein ich werde bestimmt
mit sicherheit cupcakes machen als
bisher
und jetzt das letzte produkt aus der box
last but not least barilla kenntnis
sofort die neue verpackung auf der
normalerweise hat der barilla eine blaue
verpackung rote linsen pasta glutenfrei
und reich an proteinen das heißt diese
bester ist sehr gut für menschen die
kehle und verträglichkeit haben also gar
nicht mitnehmen oder hartweizen krieg
sondern aus roten linsen ziemlich cool
ich bin gespannt ob sie auch nach rot
man das wirklich schön raus schmeckt
dieser roten linsen ich mag rote linsen
fährt er hat noch kein proteinen und
rohstoffen zudem und es gibt drei sorten
das heißt du hast jetzt die musik drin
genau die penne mit roten linsen und es
gibt keine aus kichererbsen holen also
das heißt dann bekommt man eine dieser
drei alles ok ich hab' fossilien aus
roten linsen und jetzt bin ich mal
gespannt darauf was ich daraus zaubern
werde man sich übrigens auch noch sagen
wollte der daniela erachtet ja echt
immer drauf das ist so wenig verpackung
wie möglich hat das heißen
ihr habt hier diesen hochwertigen karton
und was ich letztes mal schon gemacht
habe ihr habt ja auch hier diese
akkupacks mit dabei die könnte jetzt
einfach wieder einfrieren und weiter
verwerten und ich habe hier dann auch
schon cupcakes und horten darin
transportiert also habt echt ne richtig
schönen karton den er nicht wegschmeißen
wird sondern weiter benutzen könnt oder
ihr nehmt einfach die akkus raus und die
folie können es für spielsachen benutzen
oder zum fotos verstauen
also ich finde es schon eine richtig
hübsche box sehr schön und wenig
verpackungsmenge dann mache ich mich
jetzt mal an den mini gestaltung also
vorspeise hauptspeise nachtisch
das ist gar nicht so einfach
jetzt kann ich mache gar bei den
cupcakes das macht polenta polenta mache
ich so ist so
ok berufstätig für murat machen ich
glaube jetzt hab ich es ist echt
ziemlich schwierig denn ich möchte ja
alle produkte unterbringen und
mindestens ein drei-gänge-menü machen
normalerweise überlege ich mir ein
rezept schaue dann was ich im
kühlschrank habe und holt dann noch was
mir fehlt diesmal muss ich anders rum
denken
ein problem hatte ich ursprünglich mit
dem erbsen drink weil ich nicht wusste
wie er schmeckt jetzt habe ich ihn
probiert und er schmeckt obwohl kein
zucker enthalten ist leicht süßlich also
echt lecker super zum müsli kann man
auch so einfach mal zwischendurch
trinken und ich hatte ursprünglich
überlegt was asiatisches zu kochen und
das praktisch für die soße zu nehmen
aber ich glaube ich werde damit polenta
kochen so mein menü ich stelle euch
jetzt vor erster gang büffel mozzarella
mit tomaten mit einer leckeren balsamico
creme zweiter gang glück salat mit einem
mario ingwer dressing mit chatter
würfeln und orangenfilets abgang machen
unser pasta und zwar die linsen pasta
mit getrockneten tomaten mit dem
rügenwalder mühle filet mit dem
hähnchenfilet und dem gase pannen und
grillkäse und als bisher und ich glaube
das wird richtig cool machen wir polenta
schreiben also kleine taler mit dem
gelierzucker mache ich eine leckere
marmelade also einem fruchtaufstrich das
polenta berate ich dann noch in der
butter und dazu gibt es ein schock so
kurz sonnencreme
ich glaube jetzt ein vier gänge menü aus
diesen zutaten ein paar brauche ich noch
vorrath belegten die einkaufen gehen ja
okay ich brauche nicht viel aber es ist
ein bisschen freizeit machen und du
kannst jetzt ruhig war eigentlich schule
du merkst du eine und ich merke mir dann
zwei okay oder andersrum erst der zweite
mitnehmen wo es mal einkaufen
bloß haben ein problem nein doch wir
haben ein problem ich glaube nämlich der
hat mich aus wurden bewusst oder schon
geklaut
ich nehme meine kamera mit filmen des
barocken einkaufen 33 mal gemüse kann es
merken was steht gar nicht drauf
ja ich habe mir nie so ein dickeres
kühlschrank sehen so es reicht es ist
eine beleidigung einfach rasch deswegen
würde man es geht gut und wir warten auf
mich wartet darauf mich verändert ohne
mich du bist so kleine globus und wir
seine ganzen zutaten sind nur drei stück
orangen ob erschienen und knoblauch das
heißt aber nur weil ist gläser
anschnallen langguth lankische wir
müssen den gemüseabteilung war schon
einer gemüseabteilung man bisher 92
holen die leute die zeit schon im finger
auf mich gemeint
der eingang hier steht ein gang
riesengroß größer geht es doch kaum
und zwar hat sie gesagt peter knoblauch
und zwar gehen hier und jetzt brauchen
wir noch was besteht da nicht drauf du
musst auf den preis guckt da steht viel
drauf und ist und dann halt ungehandelt
hier guck mal hier stets doch riesengroß
mal bio öko verordnung ok und jetzt
verschieben
ob es ihnen meist wie aussehen weil der
ganz unterschiedlichen auberginen und
zucchini gesehen fast gleich aus das war
nicht so obens langsam
maschinenbau kg ob sich das auch gleich
die kunden zwei stücke
dann haben wir alles dann müssen wir
zahlen aber wir müssen eine info will
ich habe da so eine tolle party ja ich
habe seine karte das gehe aber jetzt
ratz fatz eingespieltes team
nein ich glaube du hast gar keine ahnung
hat wo alles bio rad kann es sein das
hat etwas angaben fünf euro sie warum du
alles schnell mussten teile daraus nicht
muss
einer muss immer arbeiten und bei
anderen muss immer was machen
der eine muss arbeit in anderen filmen
warum muss ich arbeiten wenn sie nicht
filmen kannst wenn du mit einem dicken
daumen den club
nein kein fleisch isst weiß doch den
mosley nicht isst kein fleisch
man sagt ja wenn ein hoher wiederholt
für dich ein habe ich jetzt kein machen
außerdem kocht doch von ihr essen dass
du es ohne spaß ich hatte noch nie in
meinem leben gesehen dass du man an dem
gleich gehts politik vorbei auf mich
ohne einzuholen
du kannst so wie man es sieht aber nicht
so aus als könnte natürlich auch nicht
los gehts jetzt mit dem ersten gang für
den ersten gang nämlich doch etwas
olivenöl balsamico creme 200 gramm
tomaten 200 gramm galbani büffel
mozzarella und etwas vom grünen bei
caprese boss zuerst den mozzarella
rausnehmen
dann schneidet ihnen einfach ganz
klassisch und schreiben also der erste
gang den machen wir jetzt ganz
traditionell
ich glaube büffelmozzarella das schreit
gerade dazu mozzarella mit tomaten zu
machen die tomaten in scheiben schneiden
[Musik]
und dann nehmt euch einfach eine platte
und richtet einfach im wechsel an der
scheibe tomate immer eine scheibe
mozzarella
[Musik]
so jetzt ein bisschen olivenöl darüber
wenn das ist kein hexenwerk aber ich
finde es tomate mozzarella es geht immer
und man hat vor allem immer ziemlich
schnell was auf dem tisch dann ein
bisschen balsamico creme darüber jetzt
noch das gewürz salz kann man direkt aus
der dose drauf geben und vielleicht auch
sein coach und dann ist der erste gang
schon fertig unter daniele toch vor
viren und basilikumblätter die hole ich
noch nie gemacht alles geholt
er wusste aber nicht wo das 7 er hat
eine passion bio gehört dass benny marke
so daniela fertig als ich fühle mich ein
bisschen schlecht weil ich jetzt einen
italiener tomate mozzarella so wäre aber
eine gute leistung aber tomate
mozzarella geht immer gern allerdings
ich liebe das immer noch mal kurz
probiert mal bio orangen knoblauch und
zucchini
ich wollte eigentlich auch verschiedene
ich nehme auch zu wenig vielleicht gehe
ich gleich noch mal los ich glaube nein
habe ich hab's noch haben wir jetzt aus
albstadt auberginen zucchini und sagen
ja auch nicht das ist aber nicht schlimm
rachel miner habe ich noch die reicht
wenn man erkennt sich mit superhits 100
ganz probiert mal einfach das beste
hallo ich habe eigene kanäle gerufen zum
probieren jetzt kommt demokratien nach
mehr einkaufen und schneiden es ist
nicht so dass trotz seines auftrittes
renner ist aber genau das ist für
mozilla derzeit immer für mich ja auch
ne gibt es in neapel da wo ich herkomme
immer so stadtgerichts man kann zu
sprechen finde ich frage sie jetzt im
supermarkt immer viel mehr und ich bin
ja ich finde es als vorspeise einfach
das essen einfach perfekt dann könnt ihr
das nochmal besser und ich muss jetzt
die zweite frau aus der maschine ja und
ich habe es echt noch ein könig sein
kann
aber ich habe das amt jedoch weiter
essen
ich begleite vorbereitung das ist der
salat zu einem richtigen menü gehört
natürlich auch ein salat also gibt es
jetzt einen salat für den salat verwende
ich etwas sonnenblumenöl weißweinessig
den hitchcock bio irgendwas saft die
mirakel vip mayonnaise mit knoblauch
etwas salz und pfeffer bio orangen ich
habe ich etwas pflücksalat die kerrygold
chatter würfel und etwas
sonnenblumenkerne
jetzt mache ich erstmal das dressing das
ist für mich immer beim salat das
wichtigste ist man alles andere ob ihr
dann pflücksalat neben eisbergsalat oder
rucola bleibt euch überlassen
ich muss jetzt ein bisschen
experimentieren wegen der mayonnaise und
wegen dem ingwer saft aber euch schreibe
ich dann die genaue menge natürlich auch
den block also jetzt einfach
weißweinessig sonnenblumenöl vermischen
ich will jetzt auch immer alles schön ab
damit ihr das gleiche leckere dressing
zu bereiten könnte knoblauch mayonnaise
ich mag knoblauch auch echt gerne im
dressing als ich bei meinen
salatdressings beim einem rezept video
auch ein dressing mit knoblauch
jetzt hab ich mir gedacht nämlich die
orangen und viele tiere see und dann
kann ich ein bisschen orangenfilets zum
salat geben und das was dann ausläuft
dieser orangensaft da passt bestimmt
auch gut auch roger irgendwo ist glaube
ich eine ganz gute ergänzung für alle
mit dem knoblauch als ich hier einfach
außen rum vorsichtig die schale
wegschneiden und dann die filets
rausschneiden und die orange und dem ich
dann vorsichtig in die hand direkt über
die dreckigen schale kann jetzt hier die
filets rausschneiden und alles was an
orangensaft jetzt herunter trifft kommt
jetzt direkt mit ins dressing und die
filets kommen jetzt auf einen separaten
teller
und alles verrühren und da kann ich mit
salz und pfeffer abschmecken und mal
gucken ob das dressing schmeckt
sie nehmen jetzt noch mehr mayonnaise
dann als schön cremig wird nicht so dünn
wird
[Musik]
salz pfeffer
jetzt geht schon ans anrichten ich nehme
jetzt eben den glück salat
da die orangenfilets geben so eine
leichte süße mit rein richtig cool
dann habe ich gedacht thunfisch passt
auch gut zu machen wir noch mit rein
eine rote zwiebel die hobel ich jetzt
noch feilen in feine streifen oder in
feine ringe auf einer linie
dann nehmen wir noch kleine paprika rot
und orange das ist etwas fürs auge und
fast auch geschmacklich gut so ich mache
jetzt eine kleine portion für murat
unternehmen dann das dressing drüber
erst mal schön vermischen ich finde es
immer wichtig dass salat und dressing
dass die gut vermischt werden und nicht
einfach das dressing darüber geben denn
dann schmeckt die hälfte vom salat nur
noch salat und nicht nach treffen
[Musik]
für den crash die sonnenblumenkerne und
dann noch das highlight die chatter
würfel im rat daniela er durch gerne
probieren geben so aus einem teller
müssen
ich glaube nicht dass unser team ist und
der jetta würfel die kann man ganz cool
leather unser mehr als snack einpacken
von kindergarten oder der schule zisch
immer ein cooler fleischersatz und vor
allem in der käse so wird sich ist dann
ist es so wie bin ich so bin ich nicht
zwei salat schon heute ja aber das erste
war der großen küche gruß aus der küche
geworden ich habe mir so gewünscht
tomate mozzarella hat er sich gewünscht
als italien aber habe grosz aus der
küche nennt sich das ja weil ich war
immer nichts mit dem wagen gegen ihn
groß aus
jetzt wo wir mal wer noch zwei gänge vor
uns morath orangensalat und dann mit
zwiebel nicht wer da jetzt noch genau
und schon verstrickt und wirklich
untersagt wird es ernst nein ehrlich es
war auf was für ein genialer die mit
maklern käse schmeckt die zwiebel und
den thunfisch war cool
nur so recht sagen dass ich mittags zum
salat esse geworden bin
denn wenn wir mittags viele mittagessen
haben dann sind wir alle danach trinkt
gerne tom jones ist ab einem ersatz
hauptspeise die kommende werde auch zu
finden sie ein großes talent ist das
haben wir jetzt wenn du nennst du ist da
meistens nicht mit aber wir essen hier
meistens im team salat weil danach kann
schaut noch weiterarbeiten
mögliche erträge also daneben die euren
salat vor allem wenn's ein schmeckt ist
kein keine legt leberkäse sondern
richtig über 32 spielen der knoblauch
kommt gut durch gern durch die manege
ist orange orangen thunfisch überlegt
doch mal diese kunden und da kam
schlecht auf kombinationen die vorher
hätte ich wahrscheinlich war ja gut dann
freue mich auf und dann gibt's gleich
die hauptspeise dann gibt es wirklich
die hauptspeise
[Musik]
für die hauptspeise verwende ich eine
aubergine zucchini 2 knoblauchzehen
sollen getrocknete tomaten von schoko
die barilla rote linsen pasta den
gasgrill umfallen käse und das vegane
müllen viele typ hinziehen
zuerst nimmt jetzt die aubergine und da
schneide ich hinten den strunk weg und
dann könnt ihr sie einfach klein
schneiden ich werde jetzt längst viertel
also zuerst so und jetzt kleine dreiecke
sozusagen schneiden also schreiben etwa
fünf millimeter und von meiner mama habe
ich gelernt dass man auberginen zuerst
etwas salz damit die bitterstoffe
rausgezogen werden
das heißt ich gebe sie gerne in eine
schüssel oder zum beispiel den fall
ziehen
und da wirklich ordentlich salz darüber
dass wir das später wieder weggewaschen
und so lasse ich sie jetzt ungefähr eine
halbe stunde stehen ist einfach die
flüssigkeit rauskommt die bitterstoffe
komm raus und danach kann ich dann
anbraten
das ist echt immer ganz gut und dann
schmeckt es auch nicht mehr so roh nach
dem anbraten also wenn ihr das mal
gemerkt habe dass er in der zucchini
aubergine angebraten habt und das war
nicht gemacht habe ich mich immer so ein
bisschen ruhe hier so ein bisschen
schütteln zur seite stellen und in der
zeit kann ich ja auch schon mal die
zucchini schneiden die schneide ich
jetzt genauso aber die muss nicht
gewässert werden
[Musik]
die knoblauchzehen einfach so ein
bisschen zu retten
dann lassen sie sich nämlich super
einfach stehlen und dann einfach auch
fein schneiden und ich kann in der zeit
schon mal nur die wasser aufsetzen für
die rote linsen nudeln und eine pfanne
für das hähnchen und für den grill käser
weiter kann ich einfach eine grillplatte
erhitzen so mache ich das
die auberginen sind jetzt soweit das
sieht man jetzt ganz gut die flüssigkeit
kommt schon ganz gut raus und die werde
ich jetzt hier einfach waschen damit das
salz weg geht
[Musik]
und dann einfach ein bisschen ausdrücken
und jetzt nämlich die sonnen
getrockneten tomaten und das öl ist
könnt ihr auch benutzen zum anbraten zum
beispiel gibt es jetzt hier die pfanne
er dürfte ruhig ein bisschen mehr nehmen
so etwa vier bis fünf esslöffel die
tomaten nämlich auch gleich raus und
wechselt den streifen schneiden
ein paar lasse ich noch drin die sind
dann fürs frühstück morgen und vom
zeitlichen ablauf her mache ich jetzt so
dass ich jetzt die auberginen im fett
anbraten bei mittel hoher hitze und
danach die nudeln in salzwasser geben
damit die daneben al dente sinn wenn die
auberginen durch sind also lieber die
nudeln etwas später damit sie einfach
nicht zu weich werden
nudeln immer zum schluss und die
auberginen jetzt einfach ein paar
minuten braten bis sie gar sind
[Musik]
[Applaus]
die auberginen sind jetzt fertig jetzt
gebe ich die knoblauchzehen dazu und
auch die zucchini die dafür ruhig ein
bisschen bis haben den herd stelle ich
jetzt auch bei der panne so ein bisschen
runter auf mittlere stufe einfach ein
bisschen mit schwenken
jetzt das wasser ein bisschen salzen und
die linsen nudeln nehmt die linsen
fossey li da bin ich echt mal gespannt
drauf
also ab ins salzwasser und dann sieben
bis neun minuten ich stellte dann hätte
es erst mal auf 7
ich mag sie eher ein bisschen bissfest
dann probiere ich sie damit nicht
überkocht hier noch den über kopfschutz
das gemüse ist auch gleich soweit und
die grillplatte habe ich hier auch schon
erwärmt und hier gebe ich jetzt auch
einfach was von dem öl drauf und den
sonnen getrockneten tomaten
[Musik]
schon auf der grillplatte kann ich jetzt
das vegane hähnchenfilet anbraten von
beiden seiten insgesamt fünf minuten und
dem käse und da habe ich jetzt die sorte
hannibal bio und schüler ausgesucht
[Musik]
so hoffen wir mal die linse die linse
nudeln ich gespannt also es riecht schon
richtig lecker nach linsen ich mit dem
prinzip minute mit linsensuppe als auch
richtig lecker und hast du noch ganz
kurz drin eine halbe minute und dann
geht es ab aber ich kann hier in die
pfanne auch schon mal die getrockneten
tomaten dazugeben
[Musik]
so war der morath kann sie wieder
startklar machen und dann geht zum
probieren
[Musik]
die nudeln kommen jetzt hier mit rein
dann mit dem gemüse schwenken aus dem
garten habe ich noch rosmarin thymian
und da will ich jetzt gar keine soße
großartig mit dazu geben denn ich will
ja auch dass der geschmack der nudeln
durchkommen das gemüse die getrockneten
tomaten wie nudeln brauchen wir nicht
immer so sei erreicht das sieht nicht
gut aus ich hoffe es schmeckt den jungs
morand sei die stadt klar ja ok
probierst du mit volkan ja und zwar ich
weiß dass es vegan ist sozusagen ja also
das nudelgericht ist jetzt komplett
vegan
okay das sind fossil aus linsen also
kein mehl ok ich hab' ich noch grillkäse
und hier noch veganes hähnchen sozusagen
das heißt ich hole zur wolke mit weil
der vulkan ist veganer
das sah man muss nicht jedes mal betonen
die muss sagen wollten es einfach freude
denn ich würde auch sagen wir ghana mit
1 2 ich weiß es ist keine krankheit ist
dieses nicht alles weg was er meint ist
und weiter bisschen salz bleibt aus
linsen ja also also nur das ist auch
nicht aus also perfekt für die und
vielleicht auch für mich beim letzten
mal wo es gemacht hast hast du mich ja
überrascht mit dem veganen im mühlen hat
da hat mich überrascht habe ich nicht
bemerkt hat gleich jetzt bin ich mal
gespannt und man hier den markt wobei
ich sagen muss ich mag nicht fleisch
mehr als hähnchen
aber jetzt mal schauen wo können wir so
ihr seid ja auch ganz normale menschen
die veganer geld komisch komisch ja okay
jetzt kann bekommt jetzt das war kein
problem
ich hätte auch gerne den käse muss ich
als wahrer kriegst du ja auch super gau
den kennen ja ok aber als organisch
gebunden der könig noch mal losgelassen
in dem video was lernt man nachher weiß
was auberginen und zucchini ich hoffe
der könig hat jetzt verstanden und ich
will sie doch kommen lassen nudel ohne
soße probiert
ich wollte nur noch dekorieren wie
schmecken den weltgrößten super während
die die nudeln die sind halt einmal ganz
ehrlich wenn ihr mir nicht gesagt hätte
ich das hier nudeln glutenfrei sind aus
lindsay jetzt nicht genau
höher sind früchte voller ballaststoffe
rogers superlecker hammer nun wirklich
kannst du öfters holen und ich finde
diesen halt cool aus ich find die farbe
allein richtig schöne tomaten auch
richtig cool ich mag auch mehr
getrocknete tomaten im nudel als
normalen keine warmen tomaten wesentlich
aber getrocknete tomaten ist womit das
ist mir noch nie aufgefallen
hab ich mal das schnitzel problem will
das misten komplettierten die kommt und
mir leid so werden alle das verpressen
mobile zuerst habe dir auch wenn euch
nichts passiert es auch dass man
spätestens drei jahren drei jahre her
und ich haben schon gedacht als ich die
packung aufgemacht haben das sieht aus
wie hähnchen und es riecht auch wie
hähnchen ja also wenn du das zubereitet
und samira sachse sind das noch paniert
und sagst dass im chicken mcnuggets sein
glaubt und ich muss sagen ich wollte
einen vorhin sagen ich habe angst gehabt
wenn wir schließen schmeckt was ich denn
sagen so ohne rollen jetzt hier zu
beleidigen
die gemeinde schmeckt wie ein schnitzel
die straße endlich zum beispiel das ist
das gefühl ist auch ja ja ich weiß
jede schnecke haben wir immer ein vom
türkischen supermarkt gab so die
talkshows den og nonsens ist und das ist
exakt die gleiche konsistenz nur
wahnsinn ist ohne spaß schmeckt die
hähnchen ist nur gesund wahrscheinlich
habe ich dachte das ist ja jetzt
grillkäse dankeschön anprobieren markus
kommen zwei sekunde bitte ganz kurz ein
problem an das hähnchen
aber du kannst es wohl ehrlich sein
jetzt wie finde ich einfach kein
händchen
nee ich kein hähnchen ich kein mädchen
schmeckt aber wie hähnchen
ach nein und probieren wir noch den
problemen noch im käse der ist mit dem
denken oder neben dem ganzen jetzt eben
ein bisschen älter werden bis ich jetzt
ohne geheimnis green screens aber doch
nicht mein englisch ist gut aber markus
hammer oder die probe meinte linsen oder
die natur
also mega okay wir gehen weiter
wir können nachts muss ich erst noch
kochen nicht meckern
[Musik]
für das dessert zaubere ich einen
fruchtaufstrich aus erdbeeren und dem
demonstriert sogar 221
ich verwende den princess anderson drink
dass da wir zwei minuten polenta etwas
vanille extrakt braunen zucker die
kinder choco bons den zweig naturjoghurt
etwas sahne und beim stefan buck hat die
s-bahn habe ich jetzt bereits fein
geschnitten und dann nehmt jetzt einfach
ein kilo früchte gerne saisonale früchte
ihr könnt aber auch tiefgefrorene nehmen
die einfach kurz auftauen lassen und
dann sehe ich die jetzt hier rein und
ihr könnt sie jetzt zum beispiel mit der
küchenmaschine zerkleinern oder einfach
mit einem stampfer nichts erdrückte
jetzt einfach so ein bisschen kommission
wissen das stück ich bleiben und dieser
diamant studiert er wurde extra
entwickelt für küchenmaschine mit koch
funktionen denn viele bereiten ja ihre
marmelade oder ihren fruchtaufstrich das
chili wirklich nur noch in
küchenmaschinen mit koch funktion zu und
da hat man auch das problem gehabt dass
die küchenmaschine ja nicht so dolle
erhitzen und deswegen gibt es diesen
speziellen jenny zucker das eben auch
darin die marmolada wirklich schön fest
wird also die canon wird die aids bis
180 grad
aber es gibt eben auch maschinen die
können nicht so hoch und da ist der
schritt jetzt sogar wirklich ganz gut
und ihr habt die möglichkeit zwei
kenwood cooking chef zu gewinnen und
zwar einmal auf dem facebook kanal von
rama.com und bei brand - und einmal in
den mitgelieferten magazin was ihr mit
dieser koch box erhaltet also macht da
unbedingt mit
und ihr braucht ihr gar keinen
zitronensaft jetzt gebe ich hier die
erdbeeren einfach kenwood jetzt den
kompletten inhalt dazu und das ist auch
ganz wichtig denn in einem beutel ist
einfach so viele mittel auch drin wie
ihr eben für eine portion braucht
deswegen immer die ganze menge benutzen
kurz einrühren und dann 13 minuten
kochen normalerweise kocht man ja den
diamanten zucker im kochtopf immer nur
vier minuten
stimmt da ist einfach die aufheizzeit
der küchenmaschine schon mit dabei das
heißt ich stehe jetzt hier einmal auf
100 grad
ich gehe sie erst noch 120 und schallt
dann runter stammen niedriger stufe
einfach rührend
jetzt gibt's polenta schnitten oder
polenta thaler polenta das macht man ja
aus mais kriegs und normalerweise mit
wasser oder milch die auf der verpackung
steht jetzt weiß er wirklich in zwei
minuten polenta ist was ganz besonders
ist 300 milliliter wasser mit etwas salz
aufkochen und mais kriegs einrühren
anschließend zwei minuten quellen lassen
das mache ich jetzt aber ich nehme jetzt
kein wasser und kein salz denn ich mache
das dessert raus und ich habe dieses
erbsen dringt dieses getränk schon
probiert und es schmeckt obwohl es nicht
süß ist wirklich leicht süßlich das
nehme ich jetzt einfach als milch ersatz
somit ist das polenta im prinzip auch
vegan und weil es einfach gut dazu passt
geschmacklich vanille extrakt jetzt habt
ihr bestimmt schon vermisst natürlich
nehmen was wirst du sehr das passt
perfekt jetzt einfach kurz die erbsen
milch aufkochen lassen
[Musik]
sobald sie kocht den herd ausschalten
dann polenta einrühren und zwei minuten
quellen lassen
[Musik]
jetzt geht es hier direkt weiter das
geht echt super schnell ihr seht schon
die konsistenz richtig gut und ihr könnt
polenta auch herz aufzubereiten ich
mache es jetzt eben süß ich habe jetzt
hier ein großes plech habe schon kalt
ausgewaschen das werde ich jetzt kurz
mit wachstums bringe ich möchte
schlitten oder thaler machen
also muss ich es glatt streichen das
geht entweder zwischen backpapier oder
eben auf so einem blech und dann einfach
eure hand etwas nass machen und mit der
hand drücken und dann erschossen
[Musik]
fertig die fülle ich jetzt einfach in
gläser bereits ausgewaschen und lacht
man die marmelade auch ab gehören
[Musik]
jetzt stelle ich noch eine schoko sahne
her mit joghurt dafür nehme ich jetzt 24
mal die sahne
die kommen in den topf und darf
aufgekocht werden
[Musik]
jetzt den herd ausschalten dann die
schoko mousse au chocolat feind rühren
[Musik]
bei den show coupons übrigens nur die
hälfte benutzen denn die hälfte ist zum
backen und die hilfeleistung nach jetzt
einfach kurz umfüllen und kühl stellen
damit die sahne wieder richtig schön
kalt werden kann gibt es das sowieso
alles abkühlen polenta darf abkühlen
marmelade doch abkühlen und die sahne ab
können in der zeit kann ich ein bisschen
aufräumen und dann geht es weiter wenn
alles schön kalt ist jetzt stelle ich
zuerst die creme her da habe ich ja mal
eine schoko sahne die abgekühlte die
gebe ich jetzt eine große schüssel was
ich hier so abgesetzt hat sie natürlich
die kleinen stückchen das riecht schon
mal richtig lecker dann der feine
joghurt und das ist ein joghurt nach
griechischem rezept ein stich lässt
abtropfen roth ganz toll gemacht sagt
meine mama auch immer die legt dann
immer papier noch mit rein damit ich
feuchtigkeit noch mit aufgesaugt wird so
stichfest mit nur 0,2 prozent wird ohne
zuckerzusatz
[Musik]
das gericht hier mit der schoko sahne
dann kommt da noch mal sahen im dazu
kalte sahne
[Musik]
und jetzt nehmt ihr einfach entweder ein
kontrollgerät und können das ganze steif
schlagen oder und das probiere ich jetzt
ich nehme jetzt hier die flasche kennt
ihr wahrscheinlich alle da habe ich
meiner mama für immer sahne steif
geschlagen ich muss aber die kerne jetzt
raus ziehen
das heißt hier einmal durch ein sieb
streichen wenn ihr die sahne mit dem
handgerät aufschlag dann müsste die
canon nicht herausstreichen außer ihr
mögt sie nicht aber ich meine dass in
der hasengasse ich schmeiß die auch
nicht weg sondern die werden dann
einfach kraft aber in der sprühflasche
wird es jetzt einfach nur die krisen
verstopfen deswegen muss man hier schön
alles raus streichen
aber wie gesagt vernaschen könnt ihr es
[Musik]
dann verschrauben da kommt da einfach so
eine seine kappe drauf es kurz und jetzt
einfach ein paar mal schütteln
[Musik]
das stellt sich jetzt ganz kurz in den
kühlschrank und kann in der zwischenzeit
schon mal die polenta schnitten also die
taler machen polenta ist jetzt richtig
schön fest und ich kann sie hier heraus
nehmen am besten direkt auf den teller
oder auf eine tortenplatte stützen auch
seine partnerin das geht echt ganz gut
und jetzt nehme ich einfach ausstecher
dem jetzt die bunten ausstechen schön
ist ist er also kleine fahrer kann ich
jetzt hier ausstechen und ich mag den
rest den schmeißen dann natürlich nicht
weg den freudig später einfach noch mit
an die polenta schmeckt jetzt schon gut
aber ich würde sie gleich noch
karamellisieren dann wird es natürlich
noch leckere jetzt nämlich die
weihenstephan butter das besondere daran
ist da steht schon darauf sauberes
öffnen
also ich habe ich hier die seitenteile
die habe ich an dann die rote asche
aufrichten und die rote laschen
auseinanderziehen denn meistens hat man
ja das problem dass die finger in der
butter landen
jetzt war gestand bleiben sauber und
jetzt nämlich die butter die kommt jetzt
hier direkt in eine beschichtete pfanne
[Musik]
und ich packe einfach den rest 1 durch
die schutz versiegelung auf dem papier
hält die butter einfach auch im
kühlschrank länger frisch da gibt's
jetzt noch braunen zucker dazu denn die
polenta ist im moment noch relativ
neutral also weder seitlich noch süß
durch die vanille hatte so einen
leichten eigengeschmack also in vanille
geschmack und jetzt gebe ich praktisch
durch den braunen zucker die süße mit
dazu so jetzt einfach kurz
karamellisieren lassen
jetzt lege ich die polenta thaler rein
nacheinander und brate jetzt einfach an
beiden seiten an bis sie schön
karamellisiert sind
[Musik]
[Applaus]
die polenta karamellisiert noch ich
gucke jetzt mal ob meine fahne schon so
weit ist
drückt mir die daumen ich mache das
immer erst auch eine probe teller als
erstmal ausprobieren
[Musik]
ich sehe diesmal mini also mini mini
minimal weiß also noch ein zwei mal
schütteln bis da war das jetzt das hotel
war muss ich ihn auch problemlos in
istanbul hat probiert ich weiß noch so
sagt er schmeckt wie ein leckerer
joghurt immer wenn jemand dass er
schmeckt der sagt das schmeckt wie
joghurt wohl gut nicht zu süß und durch
leichte säure des joghurts in echt gut
jetzt geht's am richten jetzt nämlich
noch ein paar show coupons die werden
jetzt noch klein gehackt so als krank
oben drauf und es ist jetzt auch ein
dessert das kann man gut vorbereiten ihr
könnt ihr die polenta schon vorbereiten
die taler ausstechen und kühl stellen
die sahne kühl stellen die marmelade
vorbereiten und dann wenn ihr es
erwähnen wollte einfach kurz vorher
alles zusammen setzen ratifiziert die
schoko borg robben schießt dann dies
selbst gemachte marmelade und dies auch
wirklich richtig schön fest geworden
super die ruhig noch mal drückt durch
damit sie chronisch werden und ihr seht
ich hab keinen zitronensaft benutzt und
trotzdem ist er richtig schön rot und
nicht frauen geworden
davon habe ich jetzt hier mal so eine
flex auf den teller
da karamellisierte polenta obendrauf
ich habe mir noch nicht ganz ausgemacht
ist aussieht aber ich glaube das ist
passiert jetzt einfach mehr hat wäre
noch frisch dazu lieber cloud wissen
wieder deine etwas fehlen
die sahne und die mache ich jetzt nicht
obendrauf denn die polenta thaler sind
noch ein bisschen warm also ein tütchen
nebendran ich glaube dass wir jetzt ein
schöner kontrast
denn die etwa sind fruchtig leicht
säuerlich die same ist cremig schaumig
nussig schokoladig die polenta ist
karamellisierte er fest dass ich bin mal
gespannt was die jungs jetzt sagen ich
hoffe sie bemerken die verschiedenen
texturen vorrath dann ihr könnt kommen
und das ist eigentlich ist es eher
wahrscheinlich immer zu sozusagen ein
steckenpferd richtig meinte ich kenne
mich mit ist und ich mich einfach sagen
jetzt erst mal spaß beiseite also du
hast heute morgen diese ganze macht von
von produkten gehabt so was ein cooles
ding nach dem anderen gemacht und ist
für mich dauernd die macht das muss man
es erst als als erstes sagen bei mir
auch so spontan ich werde unser denken
und ich muss ehrlich sagen du hast viele
formate auf dem youtube-kanal das macht
gemacht dass gemacht das gemacht und ich
bin 1 der kurzen formate finde ich das
mit brian hughes ich hab schon immer
coole sache da ist man was macht sie
jetzt daraus ist so etwas baut jetzt und
richtig genial wenn ich hab halt tragen
dürfen wir wirklich nicht verraten
vorher was drin steckt wird kurz vorm
dreh will ich wissen was ich habe erst
gedacht cupcakes aber kann ich dann doch
zu langweilig ich bin gespannt und
polenta habe ich einmal gesagt
zubereitet für mein neues buch herzhaft
aber noch nicht selbst
süßes polenta süße polenta ist die
palette nehme das jetzt ohne spaß hier
soll hammer mich inspiriert man sagen
kann es ist ja es hört sich vielleicht
eines seiner frau wenn irgendwas möchte
nein ich möchte nichts von dir zu essen
ja ich glaube ich bin jetzt auch wieder
fan von polenta hammer angeht
superschnell
ich bin auch nicht so dass wir nicht so
gut in so einem nobelrestaurant ist und
wenn so ein ding ja und ich finde dass
der meist recht gut durchkommt das
stinkt die die polenta so zu benutzen
die marmelade super wahnsinn ja fürs
buch habe ich sehr herzhaft gemacht da
haben die talente schnitten mit
champignons und das doch mal gut mit dem
zucker ausnahme ist echt gut waren die
marmelade ist auch ich mache es nicht
nach aber könntest du mir mal ich mach
es nochmal für dich und wenn du den atem
an
sie ist nun eben nicht nur vorteile da
für mich ja weil eine müll raustragen
also ich find das format auch echt
ziemlich cool denn ich denke ich wäre
auch dieses menü niemals gekommen wenn
ihr mir nicht die produkte in die box
gesteckt hätte also da stimme ich was
mache ich habe anfangs kurz gedacht oh
mein gott was mach ich jetzt und kriege
ich alle produkte unter aber ich hab's
geschafft der mir aber was vielleicht
dazu sagen möchte ich habe jetzt viele
angefangene produkte auch noch ein
kühlschrank im vorratsschrank ich bin
die box echt ziemlich cool also alles
was jetzt drin war fand ich super
du kannst auch war mit hähnchen kohl war
jetzt hängt damit die fläche die leser
haben vielleicht der krise mit dem neuen
geschmack
die wand schufa meist reges polenta also
eigentlich alles seins frank ich habe
jetzt nicht nur jetzt den bock zum
gärtner abgearbeitet
wohin hast du das ding verbaut diesen
erbsen saft die erbsen milch wird als er
diesen trinkt der ist immer in dem in
der polenta nachdem freunde der
morgensonne probieren
ich hab noch was ich eben sagen wollte
ich habe jetzt praktisch alle produkte
für ein menü verbraucht aber im prinzip
wenn man die box hat na ja wirklich was
für viele tage und für viele - also man
ein normaler mensch und ich will jetzt
kein normaler mensch strahlt die
challenge alles zu verbrauchen
aber der hat ja im prinzip lebensmittel
für einen längeren zeitraum hat die
polenta da habe ich jetzt noch für
mehrere portionen erbsen training habe
ich noch da marmelade habe ich jetzt für
den ganzen sommer
also warte ich hab's probiert wird
es gibt einfach manche sachen dann
möchte man einfach wissen wie die
schmecken ja ich will es keine erbsen
hassen muss sagte erbsenzähler es
schmeckt aber es schmeckt nach gemüse
und es schmeckt nicht probiert es
einfach mal
jetzt wird er nichts verraten das hammer
also ihr wart auch was wie dem
antibiotikum gefahren ist das mini gut
gemacht ich mache ich wenn ich das
format gefällt dann schreibt gerne in
den kommentaren des universität also ich
komme auf öfter auf dieses roma ich habe
heute wieder blut und wasser geschwitzt
weil ich am anfang nicht wusste was es
machen werde
aber ich bin jetzt echt begeistert doch
ich bin auch ganz zufrieden und sehr
stolz auf sie und noch mal nämlich und
bahn gibt dann jede mutation ist immer
unterstützt und danke euch und er ein
bisschen ok und falls wir die box habt
könnt ihr das menü gerne mal nachkochen
und mir dann euer feedback geben ja oder
ich will mal im supermarkt schnuppern
nicht die produkte über schon genau das
finden viel spaß beim nachkochen beim
nachmachen und wir sehen uns wieder das
nächste mal
man kann die leute halt gelernt was
zucchini und was maschine ist anderes
mittel machen sich extra zucchini
aubergine und dann hab das doch ich
verwechsle ich habe dass ich gehe mal
zum könig machen
das habe ich immer so vorratsschrank
okay also können wir wollen jetzt auch
ja
[Musik]
[Applaus]
was wir haben echt eine zucchini geholt
jetzt rating wie niemals mal kein spaß
manchmal ganz kurz juni es war eine
kurze frage was ich das was ich das
willst du mich veräppeln das sind
zucchini und auberginen wir haben es
doch davon gehabt erst mal ohne spaß
jetzt konstruiert da gibt uns drei
zutaten und von den dreizehn war eine
aubergine neben mir nicht so kimi mit du
hast du angst hatte ich hab gesagt dass
ich mich bist warst doch schwarz
typische renten wieder einsehen
es war ernst ehrlich jetzt ohne wird
alles geht es ohne du hast genommen du
hast du gehst auch der tipp der brokkoli
und blumenkohl durcheinanderbringt
blumenkohl sieht so aus wie du bist und
so kleine knospen wahnsinn hebel jetzt
war ohne spaß denn 13 zutaten wie er
sagt sie uns ob chinas premier zu
kriegen oder reden haben seitdem weiter
doch beachtenswerte genommen und ganzen
sind die aubergine ich mal was ist doch
ganz einfach grün maschine schwarz zu
geben als jetzt